[Musique]
c'est quand je te voir comme ça j'ai je
t'aime je te va enfin fermer le
périphérique ne porte le cuir en corner
par une dernière pige au huitième jour
de tournage
vous avez une semaine et demie dans les
pattes et en fait j'ai une scène crucial
à jouer mais je pense que c'était cool
d'aller à skyrock ce moment ça
représente un certain accomplissement
dans un rapport de prix qu'on plus
impressionnant je pense que c'est alain
fleury fait rêver puisque j'ai découvert
un truc que je connaissais pas vu que
j'ai pas été en prison j'espère pas
encore jean
periph pareil on a marché sur le périph
s'était bloqué un monter sur la scène du
zénith avec un micro qui ne fonctionne
pas et sans un truc ma vie en survêt
l'été au moment où on répète ou en fait
il me parle de salvatore esposito
il me parle de la complexité de ce
personnage et il m'expliquer pourquoi
c'est important que les gens voient mes
faiblesses et je me rappelle la répète
d'après je suis revenu et j'ai regardé
j'ai regardé comment rentrer tout et
c'était totalement différent je pense
qu'il pourra vous confirmez c'était
vraiment un beau souvenir le jour où il
m'a annoncé que j'étais pris dans la
série c'est un des meilleurs moments
aussi ce n'est le plus beau de ma vie on
va dire parce que je suis pas mariée
pendant longtemps je me rappelle c'est
le ramadan donc je fais et kate dormir
et du coup ils savaient que je dormais y
venaient et me foutais les doigts dans
le nez pendant le drame un tueur c'est
celle où il ya midi égard moi j'y crois
pas trop à l'histoire de formats stream
c'est parce qu'ils essaient nos baisers
et je suis là j'ai cru que la
conversation est comme un coup à la fin
j l c'est quoi sa ferme à strip cette
discussion là c'est là celle qu'on a le
plus répété en castille ans répète je
crois que cette séquence là dans 20 ans
on rappellera encore
[Musique]